Ikegawa Reiko First, I gave you this opportunity
Thank you to Columbia University
Yup
I
The focus of this presentation is
Produced by the Manchuria Film Association in 1943
It is a short movie called Hanayame of Aizawa
The film was discovered about 40 years ago from a certain RIKEN farmer
Manchuk immigrant wife with young woman
That is propaganda Iga to be invited to Manchuria as a continental bride
Untitled is the first female movie director in Japan
Since the movie was imported to Japan 2 minutes at the end of the 19th century
Developed along with the imperialistic expansion and by the end of the 1930s
It came to be regarded as a propaganda for the execution of a total war
And propaganda using the film is not only the first place
It is said that it is occupied area in Taiwan Korea China mainland south coast
Beige of elements of the Greater East Asia Co-prosperity zone concept
Above all, it was made in northeastern China
傀儡 National Mercy Here was established here in the direction of the boom
The Manchuria Film Association produced a stickman's propaganda
Even if it changes to many leaves, Keikyu is accumulated from both Japan and China
Makino defending is Manchuku immigration research and above all
Man A has been defining from early on joining research
This presentation is an attempt to respond to the reduction of the volume from a gender perspective
What Is Manchurian Immigrants? What Louise Young was in the heart of the Great Japanese Empire
It is defined that it was Manchukuo country I advance it and what was in the center of Manchukuo country is the continent
Want to say she was a lovely bride
Army and Seibu
First of all, China's northeastern China
Then know the character of economic development
We carried out together and carried out Manzhou agriculture immigration business as national policy
It was considered necessary to increase the population of the Yamato people for the lasting control of the Manchukuo colony
Because
Therefore we let single women migrate from Japan to Manchuria
And I thought it would be a big problem of Hopper to let the children get married in the field
From a polar point of view, the bride on the continent was a single military item
Naizawa Naha says women film directors and women immigrants
It is a movie that was established from the point of view where the female role under wartime crosses
I read part of the role played by the film in the policy of aggressive expansion by reading this
I would like to decipher
Hmm
This presentation is organized as follows:
First, I would like to briefly describe the archive situation of the number of surveys
What was marketed for domestic materials and then televised
An exhaustive survey of what the film center holds
Then it is a curl outside the country, but first of all a in China
Chinese
It's just a movie library
There are a variety of lockers mentioned but here
A million yen fool movies 108
The 108 hours are held by Keimei
However, it is not in the situation that foreign researchers can use now
In recent years, works of colonial Korea came out from the Chinese Film Archive and took dvd
What version will a work come out in the future?
I want to watch the development
Then the Russian goth cut is also at Phong
The previous film held here was sold as a 30-can video product in 1994.
Was
This included whey made by Sakae Tazuko
it is America
North Sea Library and then official documents simply
It is known that many wartime Japanese films have been launched upstream, especially 10,000 yen for excited letters
At least 5 works
It has been confirmed that it has been saved
It is Britain but coal mine movie line to Imperial War Museum
I have found that there are some of the ones made below
Then it is a literature document and unfortunately it is
Most of the contemporary materials of Man a are not extant
For Manchuria reclamation immigrant materials, the white university q month related material archive was useful
Then I listened to it and then investigated the remains of Sakane
Fortunately, we can investigate the remains of Sakane, which the bereaved kept.
Also to the survivors of my colleague in the tens of thousands yen who made a hearing together
Do an interview
doing
Then it became location of feather 6 of aizawa
It is a place called Saitama Village reclamation team which made 12 large pieces
I was able to hear from those of you who survived
Then I would like to talk about my retrograde life
Sakane was born in Kyoto in 1904
Are you an underground or sexual inventor?
My parents grew up in a very rich and friendly environment for movies and plays
Exceptionally high education at that time
I will go to Doshisha Women's University, but I will marry a souvenir halfway but soon divorced
1929 Sakane joins Kyoto Nikkatsu
I was assigned under Mizoguchi Kenji no
I entered the film world, and I actually cut hair and decided to a fault like this
At the scene of the movie, it's perfect next to Mizoguchi
Assistant director editing here
I learned the job of record loneliness and scenario reworking
1936 Sakane plays Han Chinese transmission at the 1st movie
The title of the first appearance a
Young and old typical example that we separate in the circumstances of the house while the young men and women love each other
Referee tragedy
The feelings of this time Sakane are well generated and left
It was a very sassy thing to be a director to a woman's habit
However, in foreign countries, already known as Dorothy art girl's uniform, a certain amount 亭 Zagan girls etc.
Enters
Women's scenario writers besides Japanese films
If a woman's camera trouble gets into a formidable situation, I will draw with these staff in a man
Not that I want to make a movie on women's edition
However, Mizoguchi did not give the store a second chance
Forty years Sakane has been independent from Mizoguchi and specializes in acupuncture film and joins a science-based film
Here, Sakane was entrusted with the same plan of the Cabinet Information Division's performance plan.
People of Ainu in the wartime system
Is it the purpose to draw as a model?
However, Sakane rather depicted the traditional film lunch of Ainu such as the Bear Festival
I was careful
The finished work is in danger of being presented by the company's this regulation, but it is in love
We take figure of youth rise and are built in construction
Next was Sakane's vision of a continental bride-themed movie
My boss's Soichi Oya was also comfortable but Otani will move to the infestation in the autumn of 41, even on a slope
At the end of the year, I moved to Man a by Otani's connection.
The Manchuria Film Association, founded in 1937, consolidated films from Manchuria
It is an organization with a huge bath pattern
The director at the time of joining Sakai is Masahiko Amajima
It is a person who is said to be involved in Karuta's trick behind the administration of Banshu country
At that time Man A's film production division was divided into three
Sakine, who is a dilapidated sleeper, joined as a director of type mummy
Sakane creates works like the above with Man 3
In terms of numbers, it is the first work of a Knights and a child with a sickness
Thing
Only the person who attached the old map Rushio has confirmed its existence
This list mother is
Sakane for Chinese Women and Children
I can understand well that it was needed for 10,000 yen
Sakane could not make a piece of work in a way that I thought was asked by a woman's niece 3 at any house
Sakone is the first to enter a colonial film company
It became possible to make a constant film
However, it was a woman gendered one or more
Food also looks nice
Aizawa Naha Nabe depicts life in Manchuk Pioneer Village lightly, focusing on a couple of leading couples
And finally it ends where the baby is born on the harvest festival
It is a short film 20 minutes
At first glance it looks like a documentary
By the testimony of the survivors of the pioneer village
Sakane gives the members a good different from reality
It turned out that I took action and filmed it in a drama format
I especially changed the water of the tube I took
A lot of 4,000 single women in mainland plum blossom are shown in the film
This is the students of Sakabe and the fireworks display of the mainland of Shinjuku
The first feature of this film is the thinness of propaganda speed
It was written for example on a day when a woman wore
It is expressed in encrypted form such as the next book called Ichitokuichishin, but this can be understood
I do not think there was a crowd
Next is the relationship between male and female equal love
For example, if you make a mistake
There is a scene that the shot which gets water from the sand comes in, and then it gives it to the horse her husband brought
Continue
My husband drinks water from a well.
And in the parlor where my wife chooses that and water
Each shot will be transferred
My fathers are extremely childish and take care of their children
It is interesting to note that the children he brings up to seven are completely distracted from militarism
is
The glider that the whole house built is a man of May, and it lands on the nose with a soft nose.
The scene etc. was an unbelievable contractor considering the real machine of 1943
Why in the film world at that time?
Because the glider was the attribute of the English black boy
When I liked this scene for a movie, Sakane incorporated the image of a good Hansen into the movie
I can say that I was determined
Ah ah ah
Lastly, it's a questionable system
Gender equality makes the family's way and load possible rooms that can be used to ensure childcare safety too
It is common use of life
In the movie, the co-cooking co-career nurse's nurse seeks to finish the care with the child
U-no processing and durability are done
As a result, Manchuria's reclaimed land is drawn out as a man-actor ward-like utopia with a life-long peace of mind
It became
We will move to the examination of this slow and gradual relationship with pioneering and Manchurian immigration policy
There was actually a harsh scene in the production background of the film depicting utopia in this way
First of all, Manchukuo itself Manchukuo itself is positioned as a vocational base for the implementation of the Pacific War
Flower buds will be chased by farming work to increase production
Naturally the care of the child becomes thin
Second mortality rate increases
Further medical e + tree can not catch up
Abnormal pregnancy delivery rate was extremely high
The contradiction between the general mobilization system and the secondary insurance bond will be expressed as such clear data
For the first time
The measure is finally taken out from the administration
Goat and milk talent seek for breast milk shortage measures
Joint figures and day care establishments during the farming season
It is insurance deployment etc.
And
All these were drawn into the nose and eyes of Aizawa
But co-cooking grounds and co-nursing schools were not in the game Saitama Village.
These facilities written were Yarase submitted
That is, Man a works with the immigrants in this Baba movie for the florist in the continent
We plan production
A lot of infrastructure that has not been realized yet had to be drawn in there
And as a director, he originally longed for the continent Naha dam theme
That is why my reverse eye was rested
Conversely, the ability of female immigrants to advance and regress is the key to making the women director's own desire for decay
The situation where it is abused to the fullest to carry out the war
I had to wait for the emergence of the situation
The uniqueness of Sakone can be clearly understood by comparing it with a manchurian film created at the same time
Japanese films have a national and popular desire for the vast area of ​​Manchuria
long
It was the media that I drew, of course the center of the film was militarized
It was occupied by a male image
In other words, underground video of housework child care drawn by Sakane
And the male image that was completely separated from the war
Both public measures in the reclamation area and the war model
It was also separated from the gender norms required by the war system
It was the image of Orizara Sakane
At the end of Aizawa's flowers and fruits, they buy a horse and take off the fans
The appearance of samba appears
A boy corps made under the wartime is proud of Mitsuda with more achievements in the movie
Finding a real female image is a good thing
Now there were three birds in the Saitama Village Appraisal Countermeasures Team
However SAKANE chooses another young woman without using her and with Japanese yen
Put on a horse
Because she was the only woman who made horseback riding better
It is the second of the adventures in which the bereaved is overrun and the Japanese boy plays an active part without red sunset in a sense Manchu
It was also a strong counter for the colonial film pair that had been
But again, so much to visualize the relationship between the buff sugar movie and the woman
There is no image The first thing she runs through
It is nothing less than what I took away from here that Japanese life is born and dropped
The rule of the country meant to be an image nation
It is a conclusion
Sakone slipped through the wall with women's discrimination and wartime film control
Man A became a female director in putting himself in a colonial propaganda organization
She was able to continue to be a filmmaker
Perhaps Sakane has all the criticisms of the fascism and colonialism
did not
The target of Sakane's resistance penetrates the Japanese film world
I was limited to the second generation central and militant values ​​there
In order to create a world of works that is completely different from the male director, Sakane
The trace of the ability to shake down the waterfall is clearly marked
There is also a movie related to Manchu immigrants that even other wartime lower Japanese films never make
It was not
Peaceful, full of life and influenced by gender
A male image and a female image are active
The royal road music soil to the slogan of Mark Manchukuo countries such as the Five-City Kyowa
Add only one idiom of gender equality
The aim that high sound aimed at in the flower buds of measures can be agreed as such
But it was a complete castle with other slogans
There are few screening records of Aizawa's flower picture dream, and this film has affected how immigrant mobilization
I do not know
However, activities in the spread of Sakane, not limited to the nose and eyes of pioneering, can not escape historical criticism
can not
It would be a pleasure to give my own answer to the first proposal to protect Makino
Sakane is a field that is unexpected for male coaches who shake pens in Manchukuo
It played a part in the imperial aggression
Please look at the book which seems to be no further consideration Thank you for your attention
Yes